それで苦行っていうのは散々批判したブッダも
自分の修行を教える場合は
それでも結局体のところから始まるんですよ
だから苦行も体のことなんですけどね
体をいじめ痛めることで苦行ですけど
いきなり心だけの成長しようということではなくて
お釈迦様もやっぱり体から体の行から始めましょうというところになるんです
そうなってくると いくらでもまた苦行ではないかということにもなります
しかし 論理的に お釈迦様がこの体と心には相互依存ということがありますから
そういうところは利用するんですね
もし体か心かというと
問題で 現代では宗教さえも体のために行うもの
現代ではみんな宗教に走り回すというのも体のためなんです
ご利益のために あるいは家庭円満のためとかね
そんなのはもう安産とかね
子宝に恵まれ 全部体の目的なんですね
天国に行く 行きたくなっても
それは天国で永遠に肉体的快楽を味わえるからです
天国に行くために宗教に行く人もいますけど
彼らが考える天国も何のことなく
もう天国で永遠に肉体を刺激させて楽にいられるではないかという肉体信仰なんですよ
もし天国では肉体はありませんと言っちゃうとやめます
体のために心があるという立場になります
だから 俗世間の考え方は
体のために心があるのではないかと
例えば 脳のことを教える場合は
脳が心もちゃんとやってくれるんだというふうな話なんですね
仏教では心が支配者で
体は単なる物体 道具 壊れるもの
借り物です 仏教はもう体には全然価値を入れていないんです
体っていうのはもう道具
借り物 どうせ壊れてしまうもの
ということにするんです
だからいきなり仏教は肉体主義を信仰を否定するんです
体は肉体を気にするなと
あんなのはもう借りたもんだからね
どうせ返さなくちゃいけないんだから
借り物を上手に使用するべきです
借り物だからそれを上手に使わなきゃ訳があって借りたんだから
体はね そういうことで
この借り物たる体を上手に使う方法
心は体を 心は体を支配するから
体の状況は心の状況にもなります
だから心が体を支配しているんだから
体の状況っていうのは心の状況なんです
この支配者は同じことでしょうね
支配者の気分次第で全部変わりますからね
例えば 家にいるみんな怯えているんだったら
怖くて震えているならば
家の主人がかなり激怒しているということでしょう
心は病気な人の体も 良くないので
ですから 例えば精神的な病気の人いるでしょうね
精神的な病気の人の場合は決まって体の調子も悪いんですよ
心が悪いんだけど 体格があって元気モリモリだっていうことはありえないんです
調べてください データを
私は取ったことはないんですけど
精神的に問題ある人々の体格
体の肉体の調子はどうでしょうかと
調子良くないんです 肉体も
肉体だけはものすごい健康そのもので
心はおかしいということだけは成り立ちません
どうしても一緒になるんです
体からの刺激が心を受けるので
体の状況は心に影響を与えます
逆も体から受ける刺激で心が変わるんですよ
ですから 特に若者の場合は体格があって
体力があって もう言うことを全く聞かない
もう暴れ回っている人々をスポーツ世界に入れるでしょ
あんた頭も悪いし 勉強もできない
だからスポーツでもしなさいよと
野球でもしてみなさいよと言うと
ものすごく苦労してスポーツだけはする
すると何のことなく スポーツで上達すればするほど性格も落ち着いていくんです
そこでプロのスポーツマンになったところで
人間としても本当に立派な紳士になっているんです
初めはまるっきり育ちにくくて
もう暴れまわって暴れるまでどうにもならなかった
手に負えなかった 筋肉に力がありすぎて
で それで筋肉トレーニングさせると心もちゃんと落ち着いてきます
ただ この相互依存ということはあるんです
しかし 体には完全に心を支配管理することは不可能です
だからといってスポーツだけやって悟ることはできません
スポーツで世界一的な立場になっても
真っ逆でしたっけ さんのように能力があっても
イチローになっても もう松井さんみたいになったっても
それで完璧に人格がなるということはあり得ません
ある程度で まあ人間の中でリーダー的にはいられます
なぜかとというと 体が支配者で心が支配者なんですよ
それで体から一応一部は命令聞く
完全には聞かない そういうわけで
プロのスポーツマンも何か犯罪を起こして逮捕されたりはします
完全にはなりません いくらかなんですよ
それで体対心っていうことは
仏教の世界はその理論の上で中道的に管理します
理解しがたい心を先に管理することは無理です
心というのは理解しがたいし
つかみにくいし 心って何やともわからないしね
ものすごく複雑ですよ
体から心を清らかにするプロセスに入るんです
ですから 体っていうのはよくわかってますから
体から心を管理するプロセスに入るんです
スポーツと同じ道で行くんです
仏教も まず肉体から心を整理整頓していって
それから残りは心だけね
整理整頓する シーラ道徳
倫理は体の感情的な行動の管理です
仏教では真っ先に語るのはシーラなんですね
仏教の修行では戒ですね
戒律ですね 道徳ですね
修行のステップ 3つあります ３
段階です 三学と言うんです
三学の１番目の学はシーラなんです
シーラ これは道徳ですよ
シーラっていうのは体でやるもんです
しかし 道徳は行になると邪見です
戒律は体で守るものですよ
肉体業です 嘘を言わない
殺生しない 酒飲まないとかね
よく知らない 恋しないとかね
そういう全部もう体のことです
だからといって これ行になると儀式みたいになってくると
仏教は邪見というんです
戒律は悪く正しいんだけど
簡単に邪見に陥っちゃうんです
それは仏教では戒律宗と言いますけど
シーラパト 律行 これも律行でもよろしいですね
そうなってはいけません
いわゆる行っていうのは形だけで十分だという
例えば題目を万回唱えるとかね
とにかく万回唱えるという形だけに集中するんですね
あるいは一年間 朝五時に大太鼓を叩いて題目を唱えるとかを決めて
これを毎日やってるんですね
そうなってくると行ですね
それで精神的に幾分わずかな影響はあるんですけど
行になってくると もういても立ってもやらなくちゃいけないことになるんです
それは仏教は禁止するんです
戒は心の修行ですから
仏教でいうのは 戒律は肉体の管理ですが
本当は心の修行だよと
道徳によって心が清らかにならないと人格は向上しないと
戒道徳になってないんです
ただ 殺生戒を守っていることは守ってはいるんだけど
心は成長しない 心が清らかにならない
だったらもう戒になってないんです
戒律になってないんです
形だけは守っている 悪くはないんだけど
まあそれでもいいことなんですけど
それでそれ以外の以上の成長はないわけなんです
だから戒律を守ることによって
自分の人格が向上するのかしないのかということはチェックしなくちゃいけないんです
戒律に重点を置くんじゃないんです
仏教はすごい微妙なんです
仏教の戒律はもうかなり厳密に守るんですけど
戒律に重点を置くんじゃないんです
この戒律によってどれぐらい私の心は人格が成長するのかというところに重点を置くんです
その微妙なところをよく覚えておいておく
それが仏教なんです どんな宗教にもあるような同じ戒律を守っているわけじゃないんです
そのような人々は戒律自慢
道徳自慢 自画自賛ばかりをして
世界を他人を批判非難する
だからただ形だけ人格向上しない
しかし自分が苦しくて長い間戒律を守っている
その場合はすごく自慢するんです
私は年間も酒飲んだことはないんだよとかね
年間ももう何とか何とかしたことはないんだよとかね
それにしたらこの世の中はどうでしょうかとか
ある新興宗教の方々と一緒に
あの昔ですけど まあいろいろ行動することになっていて
で お年の女性でしたけど
あの どこかで二人で行くんですよ
何か活動がありまして
行く場合は駅では階段いっぱいありますからね
みんなさささっと もう今と違って前の人々はちょっと足が速かったんです
今は携帯ゲームやったり
メールやらなくちゃいけないんだから
あのエスカレーターでもじっともう終わってるんですけど
上がってね それでもやってるんです
で それは昔はなかったんだから
みんな早く 行くんで そうするとこの女性っていうのはもう体の一番悪い靴履くでしょ
だからハイヒールでね
あとよく上手に履ける履くもんですよ
あれで倒れないんだからね
そういうもう靴を履いて
もうさっさと階段上るんですね
上る場合はみんなこのかかとを段につけないんですよ
ささっと上げるだけで
そこでこの私と一緒にいたこの新興宗教の方がスマナサーラ見てください
みんな性格が悪いんだと
誰一人も足をちゃんと段につけておかないんだ
置かないんだよと で 偉そうに私に言うんですね
私はその時はまずい 私も気をつけなくちゃと
このね この女に何言われるかわからないんだと
しかし 階段を上るたびにたまたまそれを思い出したりはしますよ
もう結構前の話なんですよ
もう学生の時の話ですからね
やっぱり自分の宗教で朝晩法華経題目唱えるとか何とかとかやることだから
この行だけなんですね
だから自分はもうしっかりと階段
もうそんな人には暇がいっぱいありますから
ゆっくりと階段に足をつけて登れますけど
若者にとってはそんな暇が余裕もないし
もう走らなくちゃいけないし
だからといって階段に半分足を入れることは正しいと私は思いませんだけど
もうもし転がっちゃったらどうするのかとかね
まあそれもありますけど
まあハイヒールだったらやっぱりかかとの方がつけない方が安全ですね
本当の戒律だったら 別にそれにそんなこと見てもそんなに
そんなに気にはしない
だから戒律は行のようにやっている人々には
みんな世界が間違っているように見えるんです
私は酒飲んでいないのに
みんな酒ばっかり飲みやがって
ああ 汚い連中や気持ち悪い人やとか
そういうふうに世界が見えるんですよ
本当の戒律だったらそう見えません
例えば 殺生することは仏教では大反対ですけど
本当に仏教の戒律を守っている人だったら
殺生ばっかりしている漁師さんと一緒に座って仲良く喋ったり
ご飯食べたり お茶飲んだりすることはできるんです
漁師さんがすごい悪人には見えません
毎日大量殺生していますけどね
そういう差別感が生まれてこないんです
逆に大変ですねとかね
いうふうに気持ちにはなります
本当にすごく心配する漁師だから
その仕事をしなくちゃいけないし
しかしこれは殺生は悪行であるし
大変だということでしょうか
聞くは だから けなす気持ちにはどうやってなれるんですかね
けなすところじゃなくて
この人はもう本当に大変な落とし穴に落ちているんだから
だから他の方法ででもなんとか助けてあげる方法はないかなといって
最低お坊さんだったら
まあたまたま行って 家に行ってお茶でも飲んで仲良くして
友達にでもなってあげたりする
そうすると その人はあの坊主がうちのもう結構知り合いだよとかね
そういう点では自慢するようになるでしょうに
だから 本当の戒律を守っている人々は
何か他の方法でも この人に道を開けることはできないのかとかね
それで年を取って漁師ができなくなったところでも
やっぱりずっと仲良くしてくれた
じゃあ坊主のところに行ってお世話になりましょうということになるでしょうに
だから 正しい戒律を守る人はやっぱりすごく優しくなって人格者になります
これは間違っている場合
行になると ものすごい嫌らしい人間になっちゃいます
正しく戒律戒を守る人の自我が薄くなる
謙虚になる 落ち着く 優しくなる
柔軟性が 戒律を守る人は戒律は厳しいんだから性格も厳しいんじゃないんです
戒律を正しく守る人はよく落ち着く
柔軟性がある ものすごく優しい
すごい謙虚なんです なぜならば自我が薄くなるんです
そういうことで 戒律は苦行にならない
ものすごい微妙なものなんです
いい加減無責任に仏教は
まあこのテーラワーダ世界はあまりにももう戒律厳守する戒律宗教とか何とかというのは
これすごくもうもうものすごい誤解
わかってないんです では戒は苦行ではないかという疑問が出てきますけど
犬業 牛業 猿業っていうのも
これはインドで昔あった業で
今もないわけじゃない
犬のように生活する 牛のように生活するという
何か形を形行ですね 形式業で体を痛める
それで断食 衣食業などは仏教は禁止する
戒律は苦行と言ったっても苦行じゃありませんよ
なぜならば このような苦行は確実にこれも戒律ですけど
確実にブッダは禁止しているんです
禁止やるなよと 仏教の戒は個人に
また社会に幸福を与えるものです
仏教の戒っていうのは
この守る人に幸福を与えるし
その私が戒律を守ると周りにも幸福になります
周りの幸福になります
そういうのは戒律なんです
苦行じゃないんです 仏教の戒のほとんどは法律的にも禁止するもの
別にどうったことないでしょうに
法律で盗んではいけないでしょうに
法律でも殺してはいけないでしょうに
魚取ったっても もういろいろ法律はあるでしょうに
取ってはいけない時期あったりとかして
ライセンス取ってないともうもうもうアサリでも取れないとかね
だからもう嘘を言ってはいいんですか？日本の法律では嘘を言ってはいけないでしょうに
結局はどうったことないんですよ
仏教の戒律は 社会人として必ず守らなくてはならないもの
当たり前のことを言ってます
仏教は戒律として 社会人として守らなくちゃいけないこと
もし戒は苦行になるならば
その人に精神的な問題があるんです
もし誰かがそう言ったっても
やっぱり戒律は苦しい
守れませんと言ったら
この人精神的な病気なんですよ
明らかに だから戒律は精神的な病気でない限りは苦行にはなりません
これもものすごく覚えてほしいポイントなんです
自分には嘘をつかなくてはもうどうにもならんというならば
その人に治療しなくちゃいけないんですよ
もう病気です 殺さないでいられませんよと
人が見るとどうしても殴りたくなりますよと
言うと明らかに病気でしょ
だから戒律というのは常識なことなんです
心身は健常なら戒は自然という話です
常識的な道徳を守れない人は
精神的には健常ではありません
しかし 泣きながらでも守ってみると
心の病が消えるんです
この精神的にイカれている人々でも
泣きながらでも戒律を守る守ると
あの病気は治ります まあ私といろいろコネ作っている何人かでも
やっぱり自分が精神的な病気だからまあひどいんだけど
もう私言ってることを信頼して
もうブッダのことも怖くてものすごく頑張ってるんですよ
もう人を殴らないようにとかね
きつい言葉だけは絶対言わないんだぞとかね
自分のこれ妄想だと よくこれは妄想だとか
人は私の悪口言ってるわけじゃないんだとかね
だから人に何とか言わなくちゃ言ってはいけませんとか
すごく自分を厳しく 今本当に苦しいんです
そういう人には 苦しいんだけど
そういう人はそれでどんどんどんどん精神状態が良くなるんです
良くなるし 問題もなく
薬も減らすことはできるし
だから戒守った時点ではなんとか良くなりますよ
だから戒律は苦行に苦行になるのは精神的な病気な人だけなんです
精神的に問題ない人にとっても
どんな当たり前のことでしょうと
そんなのはという状態なんです
精神は弱い人にのみ戒は苦しく感じるんです
一般の人には当たり前の生き方になります
理性に基づいて戒を守ると心が成長するのです
清らかになるのです ポイントは理性ということなんですよ
理性に基づいて戒を守らなくちゃいけないんです
戒律項目一個一個にかなりの意味があるんです
全部まとめてみると 自我という一言葉なんです
自我 わがままで悪いことをするんです
殺生はわがままな人がするんです
親を騙すことはわがままな人がするんです
仕事 勉強をさぼったりする人も
わがままでそれをやっているんです
だから戒律っていうのは
この自我をなくすことです
だからそこをよく理解しておくと
何のことなく自然に戒律を守れるようになります
しかし 道徳戒律というのは完璧なものじゃありません
どういう意味ですかね
体の影響は心を受けますが
肉体には体を完全にすることはできません
肉体とは借り物で壊れるもので
そんな力がないんです
心が支配者で帝王なんですよ
だから帝王でもいくらか家来の話は聞きますけど
何でもかんでも家来が言うことを聞いて奴隷になることはありえないんです
帝王の気が立ったら家来の首を飛ばしちゃいますからね
だから家来に王様に何か言うことできますけど
リミットがあります だから肉体業で心は綺麗になりますけど
リミットがあります そこまで出しゃばってやっちゃうと
心が逆上して全部壊すんです
そういうわけで 戒律は完璧じゃないということになります
道徳は 戒道徳だけでは人格は完成しない
悟りは開けない 戒律だけでは解脱はできない
戒の力は煩悩を抑えることです
戒にできることはせいぜい煩悩を抑えるぐらいです
睡眠状態にすることです
煩悩を寝かしておく 目が覚めないように
しかし 戒は理性理解と伴う場合は
自我がなくなる可能性は大いにあるんです
とは言ってもなんです
とは言っても 戒律と理性が理解能力が伴っていくと
戒律だけでも相当成長はします
自我がなくなる可能性が大いにあります
しかし ケースとしては少ないんです
仏教の歴史では 戒道徳に馴染むことは
体の行は完成です だから戒律完成するということは
もう戒律は自然になっちゃう
もう普通呼吸することと同じく
別にただそんなもんになってしまう
あまりすごいことをやっているわけじゃなくて
別に普通の酒飲まないだけで嘘言わないだけでは
そういうふうに何とか戒律体に馴染んでしまう
一切一体になってしまう
そうすると 痛くも痒くも何もないんです
その人のごく普通の生き方なんです
それで戒律でできることは全部やったということになるんです
しかしまだまだその人は修行を進めなくちゃいけないんです
健常な人に戒は苦にならないんです
ですから 戒律は苦行にはなりません
それで健常な人の場合ですね
弱い人はどうしますかね？弱い人には救いがないんですかね
弱い人にはまた別なプログラムがあります
健常じゃなくて ちょっと異常な人には
仏教は別なプログラムを作ってあります
例えば 色欲が異常な場合は苦になるかも
これ正しいかどうかわかりませんだけど
まあ性的な欲ですね そこを異常
それって別に肉体的なことで
そんなにどうした問題ではないんですけど
でもその人は戒律を守ろうとすると結構大変ですよ
だからその人は苦しむ羽目になります
体が不浄だ 悪臭を放つのだ
朽ちるのだなどの事実を観察してマインドコントロールする必要もあるでしょう
その場合は その人は特別なマインドコントロールプログラムに行くんですよ
もうこれ マインドコントロールってのは冗談で書いてある
それはマインドコントロールじゃないんです
事実ですからね 体は不浄だ
悪臭を放っているものだ
朽ちるものだ 体を見て欲を作る
とんでもないな そういうふうに自分に言い聞かせて言い聞かせて
心を抑えられなく抑えなくちゃいけないんです
それはこの異常者に対する特別プログラムなんです
健常者にはそんなことなくたって大丈夫です
グルメ病なら食事の管理も必要でしょう
グルメ病だったら もうまたいろいろ食事管理とか
わざとあえて決めなくちゃいけないんですね
自分の人格的な弱さをチェックして
対処法 これ正しいかどうかわかりませんだけど
法として微妙に調整することはあります
だから戒律っていうのは
自分の性格の弱さをね
自分でチェックして その戒律を調整するんです
調整するということは
日本で調整するやり方じゃないんです
日本では戒律を捨てるんですよ
やりにくい じゃあブッダは全部捨てますよと
その道がもう全く間違っています
戒律を調整するということは
ちょこっとスペシャルプログラムでちょこっと難しくすることなんです
柔らかくすることじゃないんです
例えば グルメ病の人は出家だったら
まあ午前中なら何回食べてもいいんですよ
それ人によってね お釈迦様ある人にはね
まあグルメ病でしょうね
あの 一回食べると何かすごい精神的に落ち着かない
そこでも許してあげたんですね
まあ朝早く托鉢して たくさんご飯をいただいて帰ってきて
午前中まで何回でも  5 6回でも食べなさいよと
そうすると 本人のあの精神的な
あのグルメをいつでも食べたい
食べたいという気分が
もうお腹が空いてもないんだからね
午前中また食べてまた食べてやってくると
もう夜になってくると
まあこりこりもう時間になりましたから
もうやめたってことになるし
それで午後は落ち着いて瞑想はできるし
それ何回やってくると
かっこ悪くて気持ち悪くて
他のお坊さんたちやってないしね
もう自然にもうやめることになります
あるいは逆に一食にするとか
他のお坊さんたちはもう二食ぐらい食べてるのに
私は一食にするんです
そういう逆に だから厳しくするか柔らかくするかということは
これを心理学的にチェックして決めなくちゃいけないんです
簡単じゃないんです だから戒律を調整すると決まって指導者に師匠に相談しなくちゃいけない
精神分析が必要になります
出家の十三ドゥタンガは一つの例です
これは須陀行と読むんですね
出家に十三種類の厳しい行があるんです
しかし 守る義務はないんです
選んでもやってもやらなくてもどうでもいいんです
この十三 特別にセッティングしているのは
この精神的に弱みある人々にとって
しっかりと人格を向上するためのスペシャルプログラムなんです
特別プログラム では紹介いたします
この十三の須陀行 一パンツ氷寒寒紛争営業というんですね
そういう衣を着ないで
人々が捨てたものを拾ってきて
もう汚れたもの 使えないもの
捨てたものを拾ってきて
洗って縫い合わせて着る
もしおしゃれだったらね
シャネルの服しか着られませんよという人で
もしかするとそんなことをやった方が逆効果でどうですか？今はと
どこまで再起であんた馬鹿やっていたのかということも自分で気づく可能性はあります
紛争っていうのは この捨てたもので衣を作る
三手仕切り宦官手血割り宦官というものは
サンゲ行 いつでもサンゲを揃って体にまとってしっかりとしている
で サンゲもまとっちゃうと
いつでもなんかすごい厳密に正式的な気分になるんです
我々もお寺でも上の衣を脱いじゃって
腰巻きだけでいる ほとんどいたりはしますけど
上半身は裸で その時はあっち走ったり
こっち走ったり 屋根に登ったり
いろんなことをやっています
あの水が流れる下水道というものもない
そういうところは全部一生懸命掃除をしたり
庭の掃除をしたり もう労働をやっているんです
もしちゃんとサンゲを着ていると
正式的な坊主で歩く時も気をつけるし
喋る時も気をつけるし
ですから ちょっとしたことでふざけがち
ふざけてしまう坊さんだったら
やっぱりサンゲ行 これ結構厳しいんですけどね
きちんと正式的に衣を着ているということは厳しいんだけど
それやったりする ピンダパーティー宦官というのは托鉢行ですね
自分の食事は托鉢のみということにする
そうすると食べ物を期待したりすることはできなくなっちゃう
人が招待しちゃうといくらか推測できます
何か美味しいものを 大体人間というのはご馳走する場合はまずいものをあげるということはないんだからね
ですから まあそういうことはなくなっちゃうんで
何がもらうかわからない
はい サパダーナチャーリカンガンっていうのは
この司馬相撲乞食行 ということは
托鉢に出てくると ある街に道路に入ったら
その一軒一軒一つも飛ばさないで托鉢に行く
で 飛ばしてもいいところはお釈迦様言ってますよ
宗教信仰違う人の場合は
その家を飛ばさなくちゃいけないし
またたくさんありますけど
あの飛ばす飛ばしなさいと
こういう家はとかね あげるものっていうのは全くもなさそうな
貧困などん底のひと言で言ってみたら
こそっとその家を飛ばした方がいいんですよ
なぜならば その人にとってはすごく気持ち悪くなるというかね
もうお坊さんも来ているのに
何もあげるものないんだから
なんで私は不幸だっていう風に
その思いをさせてはいけないんです
だからしかし あのサパダーナ
この司馬乞食行になってくると
だいたいこの町にある 100軒も訪ねるぞ
200軒も行くぞということじゃないんです
そうすると贅沢ですからね
だいたい 15軒とかね
20軒にしましょうとかね
10軒にしましょうとか決まったら
その始めた時から順番に 10軒に行って
適量もらってももらわなくてもそこで切る
引き上げる それは厳しい行なんです
エーカーサニカンガンというのは一食行
何か口に一回入れて 手を洗って口を洗ったら
また次の日まで何も食べないって
これも大変ですよ 例えば托鉢に出ようかなと思ったところで
信者さんが誰かが来て
子供でいいんです ちょこっとお菓子とか何かあってね
お坊さん これお菓子一個あげます
食べてくださいと お坊さん
はい わかりましたと 今食べてくださいってちゃうと食べなくちゃいかんね
食べちゃうとまた食べられなくなっちゃう
その日は なぜならば 1 色だから
1 色は口を洗ったことで
手を洗うことで食事終了という意味なんです
だからそれでもう終わりって
もう一つ パッタピンディカンギガン
これは何でしたっけ？八色教
これは食器何も使わない
鉢だけ 食器一つだけ 自分の鉢だけ
水飲む時でもその自分の鉢で水を飲む
ご飯食べる時でもそれでご飯食べる
別にそれ楽でしょ？別にどうったことないでしょ
そうじゃないんですよ
ちょっと考えてください
お坊さん ちょっと水いかがでしょうかというと
鉢でもらわなくちゃいけないんですよ
鉢の中に何があったってももう知ったものじゃないんです
台の上にあれ乗せますからね
まずくなりますよ それで誰かがアイスクリーム
ソフトクリーム持ってきていかがでしょうかというと
それも同じ鉢でいただかなくちゃいけないんです
別のアイスクリームカップでもらわないんです
それはこちらに入れてくださいと言うんです
だからそう 楽行 これ全部厳しい行なんです
そこで食欲も自我も あれもこれも足すんです
カルパッチャバッティカンガンというのは
うーん  これと似ていますよ
これと不従受食行という
まあ食事終わってから
例えばもう 11時ぐらいで食事終わりましたと
自分の部屋に入ったら
あるいは別なところに行ったら
そちらまたバナナとか果物とかありますと
まあ食べてもいいんですけど
普通はね それはもう食べません
あるいは食事は 11時半にやるつもりですけど
まあ何かちょこっとした間食みたいなものがありまして
面白い見せられたものがあって
まあそれが 10時ぐらいでとか
食べたりとかはできません
これ重複することはしない
だから一色行と似ています
アーランヤンアーランアーランニカンガン
臨持行というのは まあこういうビル
建物には生活しない マニスマ
ピンダパーティーカンルッカモーリカンガン
ジュカジュ なんで書き読みません
で 住むところは木の下にする
特に夜ですね 夜はいつでも木の下にする
雨が降る 雪が降るということは知ったものじゃないんです
10番目はアッボーカーシカンガン
土地住行 上木もないところに住んで住む
住む行  11番目はソーサーニカンガン
これどう読むんですかね
ツカマ住行ですかね まあ一応辞書を引きながら言葉を入れましたけどね
で お墓に住む 夜は ヤターサンタティカンガン
趣味所住住行 それはこのお坊さんの間で
この自分の場所を決めてあげるんですよ
年によって体の健康をいろいろ考えて
この管理のお坊さんたちは
住むところは選んであげますけど
だから あんたこちらと言った途端
そこは何も文句も引っ越しも何もしないでそちらに住む
ネーサッジカンガン 最後ネーサッジカンガンというのはジョーサフガ行で横にならない
決して眠らないというわけでもないんですけど
眠くなっても じゃあちょこっと寝ようかなと思って
それでも座ったままで寝る
そういうのは特別厳しい行です
だから戒律と言わないんです
行と呼ぶんです それは個人差なんですよ
スッテは極秘で守る行です
これ自分の人格の弱さを見て特別合わせる修行だから
極秘でやらなくちゃいけないんです
この極秘ということは一番大事なんです
誰も知ってはいけません
だから苦行と違います
苦行っていうのはみんなに見せたくてやっているものだからね
こちらもどちらかというと苦行に近いんですよ
しかし 誰も知らせにも知らせてはいけないんです
極秘でないと心が治らないんです
例えば あまり怠け者で贅沢にすぐすぐすべすべ贅沢になりがちだったら
極秘でこの行殺不学行をやってくる
極秘だから誰にもバレてはいけませんよ
そこは２日 ３日やってくると
あの人格はたちまちもう伸びて直せます
師匠以外誰にも知らせてはならないんです
知らせたとか 知らせたところで業が切れるんです
サンガの統一性 平等 調和を保つためでもあります
もしサンガの中で一人がスダグやっているんだと言ったら
その人だけ飛び上がって偉くなっちゃうでしょうね
あのお坊さんはすごく偉いんだよと
スダ行までやっているんだよと
これは禁止です 知られてはいけないんです
で 中作所のストーリーあります
あるお坊さんがもう一人のお坊さんと仲間で一つの部屋でずっと生活していたんです
これで二人の一緒の生活っていうのは
まあなんか十三 十五 六
かなり長い時間なんです
はっきり覚えてないんですけど
とにかく十五 六 七 八ぐらい長い時間なんです
一緒に小さな部屋で二人のお坊さんが生活していた
そこで一人のお坊さんがある日夜目覚めたんですよ
目覚めたら 月の明かりが屋根にちょこっと空いてるところがあって
そこから月の明かり明かりが当たっていたんです
当たって目覚めてみたら
自分の友達のお坊さんが座っているんです
ったら目覚めたので ああ
君 何て言ったっけ？ネーサ時間がやってるんですかねと
なんとなく言ったんです
君 なんだね サッチ時間がやってるんでしょうかね
とというと 何も返事も何もせずにそのまま横になったんです
知らせなかったんです
あれほどの友達にも そこで十七
八年大事に守ってきた業をその日で切っちゃったんです
それぐらい知らせるのはダメなんです
だからこれは戒律でないんだから
破って何か悪いわけじゃないんです
どうせ自分一人でやるものだからね
だからこの戒律だけは自分一人で受けることもできます
それで現代的な社会に当てはめてみると
昔と違った誘惑は現代にあるとするならば
昔と今の社会違うでしょうね
昔なかった誘惑いっぱいあるとするならば
それらを戒めることで心は清らかになる
テレビ パチンコ パチンコ
タバコ ゲーム インターネットなどなどでしょうに
そういうものに誘惑されるならば
心が汚れるならば そういうことはもう自分の個人的な戒律としてもうやめた方がいいんです
でも人に言いふらすんじゃないんです
しかし あくまでも個人が自分の希望で決めるのであって
それが仏教だと思ったり
他人に自分の行を自慢したりしてはならないんです
なぜならば それが仏教じゃないんです
仏教の戒律は普遍的に常識的なものです
それは言いふらしたっても
笑われるだけで当たり前のことを言うなよと
これは言ってはならないんですね
他人を助けるアドバイスとして伝えてもいい
人が困っている場合は
あなたこんなこういう風にやったらどうでしょうかとアドバイスしてもいいんだけど
私はやってますよと言ってはいけません